a sci-fi movie that stars a wrestler
that's going to get a remake and I'm
actually going to say that this is a
good thing welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel so when I saw they live for the
first time I was maybe 13 or 14 and it
was on uh one of the small channels like
Channel 4 or something here in the UK at
like 10 or 11:00 at night and it blew my
fragile little mind I was already a fan
of Ry Ry Piper so I sat started watching
this film and I didn't have a bloody
clue what it was
about and but but Ry Ry Piper was in it
being Ry Ry Piper and there was some
aliens in it and there was some very
cool
sunglasses
I have come here to chew bubblegum and
kick
ass and I'm all out of
B now we use the word cult classic quite
freely sometimes we throw that term
around but they live by John Carpenter
is a proper cult classic now John
Carpenter made a couple of these movies
John Carpenter's vampires with James
Woods is genuinely one of the greatest
vampire movies ever made it is
phenomenally stupid but its glory is in
its complete
stupidity it works on almost every level
and so does they
live you see I take these glasses off
she looks like a regular person doesn't
she huh put him back on from mahy face
that's what we got that's enough now we
have had a few false starts with getting
a remake I've had to do a list so uh
2010 John Carter was down eared for
developing a new remake um a year later
Matt Reeves was put down on the direct
that then changed tact and they were
going to move away from the satirical
element of they live and move back
towards the actual sort of tone of the
original short story that it was based
on and then again in 2015 there was talk
about a remake and then again in 2018
all of which was going to be connected
with John
Carpenter now a few months ago giant
freaking robot came out with this story
saying that we were going to get a
remake and everybody ignored them
completely as you should with everything
that giant freaking robot says but then
just a few days ago we got news that
actually yes this might be happening and
my interest was peaked
all right suppose we settle down that's
far enough where'd you get those glasses
Tooth
Fairy oh
good you got him Sandy King is a
producer that actually worked on the
original they live movie she was a
script supervisor she is a producer of
many movies she's John Carpenter's wife
so you know they have a pretty good
working relationship
and recently in an interview she was
being asked about they live she was
saying that this is a story that is more
relevant today than probably it ever has
been and she was asked does that mean
we're going to be getting a new version
of this her answer there might be so I
do as I always do and sent The Feelers
out to the sources that I get to speak
to I wondered had anybody heard anything
about the lay live REM REM make was it
going to be a complete remake of the
movie maybe a
continuation well I did get an answer
but before we talk about that let's talk
about the actual original so it's not
the greatest acting in the world let's
let's kick that straight off r r Piper
was a wrestler with a lot of problems in
his personal life and he died way too
young I did enjoy WWE when I was a kid
WWF back then I lik the pandas fighting
um there were no pandas fighting um I
love the wrestling when I was a kid um I
actually loved the wrestling right up
until probably my early 30s um I love
Triple H I loved the rock I loved all of
these actors I love just how big it is
and how stupid it is Ry Ry Piper though
when I first started watching
wrestling him and the British Bulldog
were probably my favorite wrestlers
standing here
for in this movie John K very quickly
realized that look this guy he he he he
can act one way he can be Rowdy Roddy
Piper so let's just write him as Rowdy
Roddy Piper and to be honest it worked
beautifully right up to the final scene
when the alien kills NADA the
character's name which again John
Carpenter is a freaking genius you have
this homeless guy that is going to
unveil this conspiracy and what do you
call him nada
nothing it's
genius right up to the final scene where
the aliens murder n and he just flicks
him the bird it's a Rowdy Ry Piper thing
to do godamn it so why is the movie
relevant why does it deserve a remake
well the film if you haven't seen it is
basically about a bunch of aliens that
have invaded the Earth and took over
humans they look like us like many
movies before and they're using social
media and the widen media to send a
signal to make us all basically
compliant this is a conspiracy theorists
wet dream and to be honest a lot of the
conspiracy theories out there nowadays
are all about governments big
governments trying to subdue us the
people and make us weak and feeble and
to do as we're told the illusion of
freedom is in lots of way actually
literally an illusion but is the c of
many a conspiracy theories website and
then of course this complete nobody gets
a magic pair of sunglasses that lets him
see the villains he can see the aliens
as they really are in today's world I
actually think that they live movie
because of the popularity of many of
these conspiracy theories and to be
honest the reality that we are very
obsessed with and really addicted to our
so social media is even more real than
it was in the 80s when this film was
made in fact this film has terrifyingly
aged well when you really consider the
social media addiction we today live
with particularly our children who have
actually been brought up on their social
media platforms so that is why I think
this film not only deserves a remake but
I'm absolutely certain it's getting one
why am I so certain because my sources
have told me it is so apparently this is
where we're at right now so John
Carpenter with Sandy King is producing
is working with universal NBC towards a
remake of the original movie this will
not be a continuation it will be a
remake also it will not be a movie it
will be a series I'm being told the buzz
around NBC at the moment is that this
will be very much a sort of violent very
sort of sort of like think of like the
boys type of TV series it will very much
feed into the humor it will very much
feed into the conspiracy theory it'll be
very satirical and it will really be an
on the- nose social commentary and the
realities of social media today so what
are we waiting for well basically they
need the strikes to end so they can sign
an actor on I'm being told that they
have a director and they have a rough
script for the first couple of episodes
or at very least a very rough idea how a
10 episode series for a streaming
platform might go they really just need
to get the casting of NADA now
apparently they do have a few ideas
they're even looking at current
wrestlers to take on the part again they
want somebody that feels a bit like
Rowdy Rod Piper now I'm told they have
an idea on who that will be but I'm
sorry I can't give you a name because I
just don't know it but at the end of the
day that person can't sign up while the
strike is on and they do not want to
move forwards until they get that
casting right so if they get the casting
of NADA correct and we get somebody that
is actually as charismatic and as big in
personality as rowy Roddy Piper was then
we could get something very very cool
here guys a modern instant cult classic
well only if they get it right because
this is one of those films that really
they have to get right
there's not going to be any middle
ground on this one it's either going to
be gloriously brilliant like the
original or it's going to be
awful terrible poke yourself in the
eyeballs rather than watch another
moment
bad and I really don't see any wiggle
room in between so let's just hope that
they can do this Justice the original is
still a great movie it's still holds up
and if you've never seen it why not and
if they do a remake I will be very very
interested to see how they do it but
guys get into the comments and tell me
what you think is this a nightmare is
this just one more remake just a remake
too far damn it or actually is this a
remake that kind of makes sense
considering the changes in our culture
and Society is this a storyline that as
I say really fits today better than
maybe it did in 1988 when this film was
first made I think it does but what do
you think get into the comments and tell
me if you are new to the channel don't
forget to like subscribe hit the Bell
notification and do all those buttony
things also go over to
patreon.com which is our patreon website
where most of our new videos appear
first you get to see them before
everybody else and without the adverts
for a small contribution each month that
really supports the channel you even get
a free gift also go to c.co UK which is
our dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our stories
and we try to add a little bit more
detail for you to digest as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time